THIS IS THE BEST I CAN DO.
THERE THEY ARE.
THANKS VERY MUCH, GRIFF JENKINS.
I WANT TO GO TO ROY BOYD, THE
TEXAS SHERIFF.
SHERIFF, ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
YOU.
THIS RAGE OF EXPRESSED BY THOSE
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND OTHER
AREAS WHERE MIGRANTS ARE
LANDING, I DIDN'T SEE THE WHEN
GUYS LIKE YOU WERE DEALING WITH
THIS ON YOUR OWN FROM ANYONE
OUTSIDE OF TEXAS, AT LEAST
POLITICIANS OUTSIDE OF TEXAS.
BUT IT DOES SEEM ODD WHEN IT'S
IN THEIR NECK OF THE WOODS.
THAT YOU GET THIS RESPONSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF IT?
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THAT'S THE GENIUS IN WHAT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS DONE.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
SPECTRUM, THE LIBERAL SIDE
WANTED TO PRETEND LIKE NOTHING
IS GOING ON AND EVERYTHING IS
FINE AND DANDY.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR DID, THE
GOVERNOR OPENED THIS BACK UP IN
TO THE NATIONAL SCENE AND CAUSED
THEM TO HAVE TO REACT TO IT FROM
A POLITICAL AND A PUBLIC
STANDPOINT.
SO IT JUST GOES BACK TO, YOU
KNOW, THE DELIBERATE MIND OF THE
GOVERNOR AND WHAT HE'S DONE TO
TRY TO BRING THIS PROBLEM BACK
IN TO THE SPOTLIGHT WHILE IT WAS
BEING IGNORED.
>> Neil: REPRESENTATIVE
HERNANDEZ REPRESENTING MARTHA'S
VINEYARD MADE A STATEMENT, THESE
IMMIGRANTS -- HE'S ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WERE NOT MET WITH
CHAOS.
THEY WERE MET WITH COMPASSION.
WE'RE A COMMUNITY AND A NATION
THAT IS STRONGER BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRANTS.
BUT AGAIN, BY CALLING THEM
IMMIGRANTS AND NOT ILLEGAL AT
THE FACE OF IT, THAT GETS MAYBE
TO THE CORE OF THE PROBLEM.
NO ONE IS DISTINGUISHING.
A LOT OF THESE SANCTUARY CITIES,
THEY'RE NOT DISTINGUISHING.
YET THEY DON'T WANT THOSE
IMMIGRANTS.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES THIS KIND OF
WEIRD.
>> WELL, THEY'RE ALL REAL GOOD
ABOUT EMBRACING THE THEORY OF
WHAT THEY ESPOUSE, BUT THEY'RE
NOT REALLY GOOD DEALING WITH IT
FROM THE ACTUAL PERSPECTIVE OF
SEEING IT ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
AND YOU KNOW, THEY TALK ABOUT
THIS.
THE SPOKESWOMAN FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE TALKS ABOUT COMPASSION AND
ALL THIS STUFF.
BUT IN REALITY, THE INHUMANE
SIDE COMES FROM THE FACT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
A COMPLETELY OPEN BORDER.
WE HAVE TURNED OVER OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR BORDER
OVER TO THE CARTELS AND THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT AND THEY'RE
ENSLAVING THESE PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY GET OFF OF THESE
BUSES, THEY'RE NOT JUST FREE TO
GO WHEREVER THEY WANT AND LIVE
THEIR LIFE.
THEY STILL OWE MONEY TO THE
CARTELS.
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE TO GO
TO WHERE THEY WERE ASSIGNED AND
HAVE TO GO IN TO SERVITUDE.
OBVIOUSLY THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR TALKING HEADS TOOK A
REALLY GOOD POINT FROM JOSEPH
GARPLE SAID WHO EVEN A LIE
BECOMES A TRUST IF YOU TELL IT
ENOUGH TIMES.
>> Neil: I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR
SURE.
BUT THERE'S AN INTERESTING POINT
AND NOTION THAT THEY'RE
IMMIGRANTS.
I HEARD IT FROM NEW YORK MAYOR
ADAMS AND THE WASHINGTON MAYOR,
THE CHICAGO MAYOR THAT THIS IS
BAD TREATMENT.
AGAIN AND AGAIN, THEY SAY
IMMIGRANTS AND OUR WELCOMING
NATURE.
SO IF THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE THESE
MIGRANTS AS ANYTHING LESS THAN
ILLEGAL, AND THEY ARE SEEING
THEM AS ILLEGAL, THERE-IN LIES
THE PROBLEM.
THAT TELLS YOU THEY DON'T SEE IT
AS A PROBLEM.
TWO MILLION MIGRANTS TRYING TO
GET IN.
THEY DON'T SEE THAT AS AN ISSUE.
THEY'RE NOT ILLEGAL.
THEY'RE IMMIGRANTS.
WE HAVE TO TREAT ALL IMMIGRANTS
EQUALLY, THOSE THAT GO THE LEGAL
PROCESS AND THOSE IN THIS CASE
THAT DON'T.
THAT DOES NOT HINT OF ANY
PROGRESS ON THIS.
>> WELL, THERE'S NO DESIRE FOR
PROGRESS.
THERE'S JUST DESIRE TO CONTINUE
ON WITH THE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE.
IF THEY WANTED PROGRESS, THIS
WEEK WHEN I DROVE ALL THE WAY
OUT FROM NOGALES THROUGH TEXAS,
I WOULDN'T HAVE DRIVEN THROUGH
BORDER PATROL CHECKPOINTS THAT
WERE UNMANNED.
I WENT OVER 950 MILES THE OTHER
DAY DRIVING HOME FROM NOGALES
AND I FOUND ONE CHECKPOINT THAT
WAS MANNED.
THERE WAS ONE PERSON IN THE
CHECKPOINT.
HE WAS WAVING PEOPLE THROUGH
BECAUSE WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO
WITH A LINE OF 1,000 CARS DOWN
THE HIGHWAY?
WHAT IS THE ONE AGENT GOING TO
DO?
HE'S GOING TO STAND IN HIS BOOTH
AND FLAG EVERYBODY THROUGH.
THE BORDER IS COMPLETELY OPEN.
WE'VE SEEN THAT FIRST HAND.
IT CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
>> Neil: SHERIFF, IT